[Music]
meagan Markel in the middle of another
royal controversy i mean how dare the
duchess cross the queen did Megan commit
a big royal no-no some royal watchers
say the Duchess broke protocol by
crossing her legs while attending an
event with Queen it is customary for
royal ladies to sit with their knees
primly together or crossing their legs
to merely at the ankles but hold on
people we've spotted deaf just Kate
full-on crossing her legs just like
Megan did we know megan has been
learning the Royal ropes from the
Queen's advisors so maybe the leg
crossing rules have loosened up a bit
the Duchess also featured a new look
with more dramatic makeup her cheeks
seem to be dusted with a high polish
bronzer while she also wore a heavier
eye makeup the glamorous dark eye shadow
was a big contrast to the natural look
she showed off on other occasions I
guess you can say you'll stuck with me
while Harry charmed the audience at the
Queen's young leader Awards his wife
looked on approvingly her hair was blown
out in bouncy waves reminding some
people of the shoulder skimming style
that duchess Kate often favors
[Music]